it is craft week and actually in 2019
when i did the pilot audition for the
show
i was lucky enough to find someone in
this world
who i asked to be my partner in the show
he is a drew's news correspondent but
his real claim to fame is being an
insane crocheter
it's jonah larson everybody
[Applause]
hey drew i'm so excited to be here to
kick off craft week
with some crochet oh jonah i
just love doing everything in life with
you
news and stories and reviewing
documentaries but today
i can't think of a better authority to
help teach us crocheting
than you
yes i'm so excited to teach you how to
crochet
but first i wanted to thank you
for your intrepid and thoughtful remarks
on 2020. it just highlights the fact
that we need to come together as one
and heal and be thankful and grateful
for our
diversity and the fact that we're all
different and it's just so important
to come together as a nation and for
that reason that you
just highlighted that's why i'm so proud
to be an
american ah i'm
always so impressed with you jonah
and you are the definition of intrepid
and i can't think of anything that makes
me less intrepid
than crocheting sometimes because i am
i am intimidated by it but luckily i'm
in your hands
what have you got how do you get us
started how do you get us out of the
fear
and into the crocheting
the first step when you're about to
crochet
is of course the yarn in your hook and i
recommend a bulky to a super bulky
weight yarn
accompanied with an eight millimeter
crochet hook
because it's bigger so you can see your
stitches
easier and also your projects go faster
so you have instant accomplishment
which is so important in the learning
process to be able to see your work
and when you're crocheting the first
step
is to make the slip knot which is
putting the yarn
on your hook and then after that you can
begin
to actually work your project literally
if you have your tutorials
let's hop right in how do i start like
i've got the needles right here
what is the first thing i do
the first thing that you do is to start
from making your slip knot so
take the end off your yarn ball and then
just pull out
a nice distance then you set it aside
oh gosh here i go jonah i can't even
find the end of my
thing by the way of course i pulled the
end of this thing and i started
unraveling the one thing that was
crocheted
oh gosh joe did this okay does anyone
have a scissor
ah jonah what have i done wrong
oh thank you arturo his real name is
arthur but i call him arturo thank you
okay now what by the way this is
literally taped
down i don't know why but okay look at
what i've got jonah
two needles at an end
so well i have to correct it's a crochet
hook needles are for knitting oh okay
by the way i did knit a sweater or no a
scarf once for an ex-boyfriend and he
kindly wore it which was very kind i
i know it was a sad scarf but he was
nice about it
okay what do i do
so you're first gonna just take the
strand
and then just turn it and and then just
make a little loop
okay like so okay
you're gonna take the longer strand
attached to your urine ball
uh-huh and push it
up through that loop like so
oh my gosh jonah jonah i
ish and here's the important thing what
everybody needs to know is that
look jonah
and then all you have to do is just pull
the two strands at the bottom
and then you can just insert your hook
in that loop
and you've made your slip knot the slip
knot
is usually the hardest part for people
for some reason
well good news i did the first thing it
was messy just like i am
and jonah is going to be uh doing the
show
he's going to be making something
throughout the whole show and by the end
you're gonna have made something right
jonah
yes i will using this beautiful
aquamarine
alpaca blend yarn yeah you will oh i
can't wait to see it all right and on
our website thedrewberrymartial.com
jonah is going to teach you
how to get your crocheting on and be
intrepid
with the yarn and everything jonah we'll
be back throughout the rest of the show
thank you
before we jump into the news let's
quickly check in with our resident
crocheter jonah
jonah how's it going
oh it's going really really good
look at all these beautiful ridges on
the project that i'm working on
i just love the texture well i can't
wait to see at the end of the show what
you've made and guess what i've made
nothing i'm still stuck keep practicing
i will and i i will jonah okay jonah
what do you got by the end of the show
you're gonna make something
did you yes i did
here it is oh jonah
how do you do it you are intrepid and
we're gonna see you all week and i love
you so much
i love being a partner with you thank
you to everyone of the vffs
everyone at home thank you for having me
you